bonjour mes chers collègues bonjour
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres la séance est
donc ouverte le compte-rendu analytique
de la précédente séance a été distribuée
y a-t-il des observations
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous prie d'excuser tout d'abord le
président du Sénat en déplacement à
l'étranger je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmis en direct sur
Public Sénat et sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du Sénat j'appelle
chacun de vous mes chers collègues à
observer au cours de nos échanges l'une
des valeurs essentielles du Sénat le
respect et l'écoute dont vous ne faites
pas beaucoup preuve en ce moment
d'ailleurs je vous trouve assez dissipée
chers collègues ça doit être l'émotion
de voir effectivement une
vice-présidente et non notre président
au plateau je mets effectivement cela
sous le coup de l'émotion
donc une valeur essentielle du Sénat le
respect et l'écoute des uns et des
autres ou celui du temps de parole donc
vous savez je suis assez asphalte sur ce
temps de parole
mes chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Martin lévrier pour le groupe
du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
deux minutes chers collègues merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention samedi à 21h
le centre hospitalier André Mignot de
Versailles a été victime d'une
cyberattaque une partie des ordinateurs
ont été bloqués et un message de
cybercriminel s'est affiché sur les
écrans tous vos dossiers importants ont
été dérobés et cryptés suivez nos
instructions à la paralysé les systèmes
informatiques reportant les actes
médicaux perturbant le suivi des malades
arrêtons ou faisant dysfonctionner les
appareils les plus pointus c'est
barbares mettent en danger la vie des
patients et cette attaque n'est pas sans
rappeler celle qui avait touché le
centre hospitalier de Corbeil-Essonnes
au mois d'août
je voudrais saluer en votre nom à tous
le sang froid des équipes de l'hôpital
André Mignot qui comme l'ensemble du
personnel soignant en France était déjà
largement éprouvé par la pandémie et les
difficultés de l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui ils ne peuvent compter que
sur leur crayon leur papier et leur
jambe pour prendre en charge un maximum
de patients tout le personnel est à son
poste je les remercie je voudrais
également saluer la coordination qui
s'est immédiatement mise en place entre
la direction du CHU la RS l'APHP les
services du SAMU et tout
particulièrement les hôpitaux publics et
les cliniques privées du département qui
se mobilisent des travaillent en bonne
intelligence
l'intégration de l'établissement dans le
parcours de
cybersécurité pardon a participé à la
réactivité sans pareil de l'équipe de
l'hôpital qui en coupant rapidement les
communications connexion Internet et
services d'interconnexion avec le SAMU à
éviter la propagation de cette attaque
ce parcours de cybersécurité a été
renforcé à l'automne avec une enveloppe
supplémentaire de 20 millions d'euros
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
dire comment ces crédit supplémentaires
et devront nous infrastructures
sensibles à renforcer leur sécurité
informatique pour se prémunir de ses
attaques de plus en plus fréquentes et
virulentes et quel sera le support
technique apporté par l'Agence nationale
de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre Monsieur François Bon
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur lévrier
comme vous je condamne le plus fermement
possible cette cyberattaque contre
l'hôpital André Mignot jamais nous ne
céderons face à ces criminels à ses
acteurs odieux qui tentent de prendre en
charge de prendre en otage la santé des
Français
je veux moi aussi saluer le sang froid
dont on fait preuve les professionnels
de santé sur place et l'administration
de l'hôpital je me suis rendu sur place
dimanche avec mon collègue Jean-Noël
Barraud et nous avons pu constater un
calme tout à fait relatif mais en tout
cas une prise en charge assurée en
termes de sécurité et de continuité des
soins malgré des grandes difficultés
devant lesquelles ils étaient
l'ensemble des services de l'État sont
mobilisés bien sûr aux côtés de
l'établissement notamment via la
mobilisation de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité des systèmes d'information la
RS mais comme vous l'avez dit la PHP est
l'ensemble des hôpitaux du secteur qui
ont coordonné à la main du Samu local et
du s'amusonal pour la prise en charge la
meilleure des patients nous devons
renforcer notre capacité collective à
faire face aux attaques cybers c'est le
sens du plan de 350 millions d'euros
portés par mon ministère en février 2021
pour renforcer les protections cyber et
surtout le diagnostic de ces
établissements cet été suite à l'attaque
la cyberattaque de corbeille Essonne
j'ai annoncé un complément de
financement de 20 millions d'euros pour
soutenir cette démarche ce complément
vise à renforcer le déploiement du plan
et surtout passer à la phase
opérationnelle passer du diagnostic à
l'action sur des actions précises et
concrètes dans nos capacités de cyber
défense
avec mes collègues Gérald Darmanin et
Jean-Noël Barrault nous allons réunir
avant la fin de l'année une nouvelle
fois l'ensemble des parties prenantes
avec les fédérations avec l'ancie avec
la RS pour renforcer notre stratégie je
tiens à signaler en plus que cette
succession d'attaque nous permet de nous
renforcer encore plus à chaque fois en
particulier sur les actions immédiates à
prendre en compte et ce qui a été le cas
à l'hôpital Mignot je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
les paroles est à présent à madame la
sénatrice Monique Lubin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre il est en effet lu de peu pour
que vous supprimiez 14000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence dans le projet
des lois de finances pour 2023 c'est
seulement sous la pression des
associations et des élus que vous avez
reculés maintenant le froid s'installe
et les journaux regorgent d'articles
relatant les situations de femmes et de
très jeunes enfants de femmes enceintes
et de mineurs laissaient dehors alors
que le 115 ne sait plus où donner de la
tête les centres d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale ont été fragilisées
par les plans d'économie mis en oeuvre
ces dernières années la hausse des
crédits cette année ne suffira pas à les
remettre d'aplomb la réduction du loyer
de solidarité en 2018 a mis un coup de
frein aux construction de logements
sociaux par les bailleurs sociaux selon
la Cour des comptes en 2021 en France
près de 300 000 personnes se trouvaient
avant même la crise sanitaire sans
domicile estimation qui a plus que
doublé depuis la dernière enquête
statistique de 2012 le 93 est
emblématique ou par exemple faute de
place aucun des 339 appels traité par le
115 le 28 novembre n'a abouti un
hébergement d'urgence mais la crise
concerne aussi Lyon Rennes Grenoble
Strasbourg Toulouse et beaucoup d'autres
communes il y a les inscriptions
budgétaires d'un côté et la terrible
réalité que nous rapporte la presse tous
les jours et que nous avons de toute
façon sous nos yeux quelle nouvelle
mesure allez vous prendre merci pour vos
réponses Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'humain je tiens tout d'abord
à redire ici ma confiance et mon
admiration pour l'ensemble des
personnels des services d'intégration
d'accueil et d'orientation les SIAO ils
agissent au quotidien pour écouter et
accompagner les personnes les plus
fragiles ils ont été la clé de voûte du
premier logement premier plan logement
d'abord et vous le savez un deuxième
plan logement de Harbor sera annoncé
dans les semaines qui viennent c'est le
souhait de du président de la République
et de la première ministre comme vous
l'avez rappelé le Gouvernement a
souhaité n'ont pas sous la pression mais
sous la réalité de l'urgence sociale
maintenir près de 200 000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence et nous avons
ajouté 40 millions d'euros sur le PLF je
vous rappelle que ce niveau
d'hébergement d'urgence n'avait jamais
été atteint dans notre pays et en 2017
il y avait 140000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence il y en a encore aujourd'hui
198 000 oui difficile oui c'est une
situation que chaque soir les écoutant
du 115 entendent écoute et essaye
d'améliorer c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
madame la Première ministre a souhaité
que nous mettions en place une prime
pour les écoutants du 115 et nous y
travaillons d'arrache-pied pour ce qui
est de la situation vous le savez avec
Charlotte cobel monsieur comble le
ministre combe nous sommes à l'écoute
nous faisons une attention particulière
aux familles avec enfants à la rue je
réunirai encore je crois l'ensemble des
préfets de région pour tenir compte de
cette situation l'ensemble des
associations qui sont nos partenaires
sur cette situation dramatique sont
réunis très régulièrement dans une
cellule de crise que nous tenons avec
avec la dial pour que ces situations
soient le moins pénible possible et que
à chaque cas nous trouvions une solution
rien n'est impossible et tout est
difficile sur une situation aussi
dramatique la situation géopolitique
vous le savez est particulièrement
complexe et un certain nombre nombre de
familles en grande urgence sont prises
en compte chaque soir en région
Île-de-France par exemple c'est 45000
personnes qui sont mises à l'abri et
dans l'hébergement d'urgence et nous
continuerons à le faire merci merci
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
vous avez 40 secondes pour expliquer oui
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué
notamment les accompagnants du Samu vous
avez parlé de confiance mais c'est le
Ségur de la santé qu'ils attendent de la
confiance c'est bien le Ségur de la
santé c'est encore mieux vous avez
dressé un tableau avec lequel nous
sommes d'accord sur les chiffres de
personnes qui attendent nous savons
qu'effectivement le nombre de places a
augmenté depuis quelques années mais
nous savons aussi que la situation
s'aggrave pour des raisons que je
n’énumerai pas ici mais que tout le
monde connaît et au-delà de ces chiffres
que nous vous avez annoncé il est
vraiment impératif pour les semaines qui
viennent de trouver voire même pour les
jours qui viennent de trouver de
nouvelles places d'hébergement on peut
pas en France avoir des femmes enceintes
et des enfants dehors la nuit merci
chers collègues la parole est à présent
à notre collègue sénatrice madame Maryse
Carrère pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre où il y a
Grégoire et j'ai associe ma collègue
sénatrice de haut-pyrénées Viviane
la ministre depuis désormais trois ans
notre pays traverse de nombreuses crises
qui mettent à mal notre économie ainsi
après la crise sanitaire dont les
collectivités locales et notre économie
subissent encore les conséquences la
crise énergétique vient obscurcir le
ciel de la reprise au moment de l'année
où les besoins en énergie vont être les
plus importants l'intervention de l'État
est une fois de plus nécessaire afin de
permettre à notre pays de continuer à
avancer ainsi le 14 septembre le
gouvernement annonçait le maintien du
bouclier tarifaire puis le 27 octobre il
présentait le dispositif d'amortisseurs
or comme cela c'était déjà produit
durant la crise covid il semblerait que
les régies publiques exploitant
notamment des domaines pliable ou des
établissements thermaux ne seraient pas
éligibles à ces nouveaux dispositifs
alors qu'elles ont déjà optimisé leur
consommation au-delà du soutenable et il
est vrai que les régies et notamment les
stations de ski verront leur dépense
triplés et ce ne sera clairement pas
supportable les vagies publiques avaient
déjà dû faire entendre leur voix durant
la crise sanitaire pour être intégré
dans les mécanismes gouvernementaux de
soutien à l'économie il ne serait donc
pas envisageable que cet oubli se répète
aussi ma question sera simple la hausse
des tarifs énergétiques impactant
l'intégralité des consommateurs du pays
le gouvernement a-t-il bien prévu
d'intégrer dans les dispositifs de
boucliers énergétiques les régies
publics dans leur intégralité et
notamment les régies exploitantes
remontées mécaniques ou d'établissements
thermaux car on ne saurait imaginer
qu'en raison de leur statut elle puisse
à nouveau être écartées de la solidarité
nationale je vous remercie merci chers
collègues pour vous répondre madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprise du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Carrère vous évoquez à juste
titre la situation des stations de ski
et des stations thermales dont je sais
qu'elles sont comme de nombreux acteurs
économiques directement touchés par la
crise énergétique c'est une situation
que je prends très au sérieux et que je
suis au jour le jour avec mon cabinet et
je ne suis pas étonné que en tant que
sénatrice vous me posiez la question
sachez que les députés sont aussi très
préoccupés je veux d'abord saluer les
efforts de tous et notamment des
stations thermales et des stations de
crier de ski en matière de sobriété on
ne le dit pas assez mais ils ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts et aujourd'hui face à
la hausse des prix de l'énergie vous le
savez le gouvernement a mis en place
tout un type de dispositifs d'aide je
tiens à dire que toutes les structures
qui se posent des questions parce qu'il
y en a beaucoup et qu'on doit partager
l'information tous ensemble peuvent déjà
appeler leur chambre consulaire soit
leur CCI ou leur CMA ou alors leur
conseiller départemental à la sortie de
crise il y en a un dans chaque
préfecture de notre pays pour
accompagner en matière d'aide aux
énergies nos acteurs économiques votre
question madame là c'est natrice Carrère
porte plus spécifiquement sur les aides
remontées mécaniques et aux stations
thermales il est prévu que le dispositif
d'amortisseur qui va protéger nos PME et
collectivités locales à compter de 2023
sera également ouvert au régie qui ont
la même taille qu'une PME c'est-à-dire
moins 250 salariés je peux totalement
vous rassurer sur ce point je tiens
aussi à vous dire que les collectivités
locales vous le savez bénéficie d'un
soutien important avec le dispositif de
filet de sécurité qui vient compenser
70% de la hausse des dépenses d'énergie
pour les communes EPCI ou syndicat
fortement impactés par la hausse des
prix de l'énergie les dépenses des
régies peuvent être prises en charge
dans le cadre de ce filet de sécurité et
si certaines situations s'avérait mal
couvertes soyons clairs je suis à votre
disposition pour étudier au cas par cas
le cas des régies qui ne rentrerait pas
dans le filet pour finir sur une note
optimiste on en a peu ne nous en privons
pas le taux d'occupation prévisionnel
des stations de montagne pour cet hiver
ça non supérieur de 7% à celui des
saisons précédente les chiffres des
vacances de la Toussaint et les
prévisions de Noël nous confirment que
nos compatriotes font le choix de la
destination France ce qui est aussi une
bonne nouvelle on a toujours été là vous
l'avez rappelé pendant la crise
sanitaire pour les régies les stations
thermales et je vous le garantis madame
la sénatrice nous serons là je vous
remercie si Madame la Ministre chers
collègues vous avez 20 secondes pour
répliquer merci Madame aministre votre
réponse ce sera de nature à vraiment
rassuré les stations de sports d'hiver
notamment dans les Hautes-Pyrénées qui
ont Bondy à la vue de leur contrat
énergétique multiplié par 3 60 euros le
mégawattheure en 2021 170 euros en 2022
au mois de mars 590 euros prévu à cette
année au renouvellement merci encore
pour cette réponse merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à la sénatrice
Madame Raymonde pensée Monge pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire pour deux minutes chers
collègues merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre du travail après une
concertation de pure forme des
partenaires sociaux vous annonciez
récemment une énième réforme de
l'assurance chômage avec une réduction
de la durée d'indemnité de 25 % en
période dite favorable la période
défavorable qui permettrait de rester
aux conditions actuelles d'indemnisation
suppose un taux de chômage à 9 % soit un
taux que la France n'a pas connu depuis
des années cette réforme au prétexte de
la cyclicité dégradent donc dès
aujourd'hui les conditions d'assurance
revenir à 9% supposerait à survenue
d'une crise économique majeure vous
annoncez votre confiance dans l'atome
d'un taux de chômage de 5% en 2027 vous
devriez en conséquence à minima fixer le
seuil au niveau actuel du chômage soit
7%. la réalité c'est que les prévisions
ne valident pas la poursuite de la
baisse du chômage et qu'il y a un leurre
à croire en impossible levier par la
baisse de l'assurance même en poussant
les chômeurs vers des emplois de plus en
plus précaires pour masquer le véritable
objectif de une vraie forme qui vise la
baisser les dépenses et réaliser 4
milliards d'économies vous affirmez que
la contracyclicité permettra le retour à
l'emploi de 150000 chômeurs quand bien
même convenons que cela ne justifierait
pas les dizaines de milliers qui
perdront leurs droits mais ma question
porte cependant sur ce nombre de 150000
retours à l'emploi que nous vend votre
réforme d'où vient ce nombre monsieur le
ministre de quel calcul de quelle étude
merci Charles collègue la parole est à
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion pour vous
répondre merci madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice ponce permettez-moi
d'abord de reprendre les termes de votre
question vous avez dit à l'instant pour
revenir au niveau de l'indemnisation
précédent il faudrait atteindre 9% de
chômage que la France n'a pas connu
depuis des années vous avez raison la
France ne l'a pas connu depuis 5 ans et
c'est sous le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron nous sommes passés le 9,4% à 7,3%
de chômage
et vous avez aussi raison de souligner
que la politique Pôle emploi que nous
menons est une politique efficace qui
s'est traduite par la création d'un
million 700 000 emplois depuis 2017 et
encore au troisième trimestre de l'année
2022 ce sont 84 000 emplois qui ont été
créés par l'économie française par les
entreprises françaises et parce que je
devine que vous allez embrayer si vous
me permettez cette expression en disant
mais il s'agit de mauvaise emploi c'est
la première fois depuis 20 ans que parmi
les embauches depuis le début de l'année
2022 puis de la moitié des embauches
sont en CDI et c'est aussi la première
fois depuis 20 ans que dans le stock
d'emploi de l'économie française puis la
moitié des emplois sont décédés donc non
seulement l'économie française créée de
l'emploi mais elle crée de l'emploi
stable de meilleure qualité qui vient
maintenant quelques années c'est aussi
le résultat de la politique de lutte
contre un court que nous menons depuis
2019 nous avons porté effectivement une
réforme de l'assurance chômage elle a
été adoptée par les deux assemblées
149,3 je le précise elle prévoit la
contracyclicité quel est le principe de
la contracte c'est faire en sorte
d'avoir une régime d'as le chômage qui
soit plus protecteur quand les choses
vont mal et qui sont plus incitatifs
quand les choses vont bien c'est ce que
nous avons fait c'est le Sénat qui a
introduit la notion de conjoncture
économique comme critères de modulation
des règles de l'assurance chômage nous
savons que cette loi ces dispositions le
décret que nous allons bientôt prendre
va permettre de réduire une part et
simplement une part détention de
recrutement et toutes les études
convergent en effet pour dire que à
l'échelle de l'année 2023 cela peut
permettre d'accélérer le retour à
l'emploi de 100 à 150 000 personnes
c'est une bonne nouvelle et vous devriez
vous en féliciter comme vous devriez
vous féliciter du fait que depuis un an
depuis octobre 2021 grâce aux politiques
de formation grâce aux politiques de
l'emploi nous avons permis le retour à
l'emploi 300 000 chômeurs de longue
durée dans 156 000 de très longue durée
les bonnes nouvelles madame la sénatrice
vous les oubliez vous préférez faire
peur c'est dommage réjouissez-nous avec
vous merci monsieur le ministre
cher mes chers collègues vous avez 34
secondes pour recliquer monsieur le
ministre non le chiffre que vous dites
du chômage vous l'avez trouvé en 2017 il
était là en 2017 effectivement dans la
dernière année du quinquennat précédent
donc c'est pas sous votre mandat que ce
chiffre a été atteint mais si et de plus
bon vous vous réjouissez les chômeurs de
catégorie A vous c'est celle que vous
voyez mais je termine en disant que de
tous ces chiffres le seul qui est exact
le seul qui est documenté c'est celui
que donne-lui 4 milliards d'économies
faites par cette réforme sur les
demandeurs d'emploi merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
notre collègue monsieur le sénateur
Pierre metvielle pour le groupe Les
Indépendants Républiques et territoires
pour deux minutes chers collègues merci
madame le Président
monsieur le ministre l'agriculture ma
question concerne l'influence à la
Vierge qui continue de sévir dans notre
pays et ses conséquences sur les
filières palmipède et agricoles cette
année d'après l'ancêtre c'est une
présence endémique du virus dont est
victime la faune sauvage alors que les
migrations à peine débuté la façade
ouest est particulièrement touchée
malgré le nouvel mesures de surveillance
inédite pensez-vous déjà monsieur le
ministre un autre plan plus protecteur
la filière en raison des abattages
massifs évoluent aujourd'hui à 30% de
ses capacités et les acteurs éprouvent
de grandes difficultés
d'approvisionnement même dans les zones
indiennes à la veille des fêtes de Noël
c'est tout un secteur économique qui est
plongé dans un profond désarroi
les aides comme le fond de mutualisation
sanitaire et environnemental s'avère
insuffisante et inadaptée à une crise
d'une telle ampleur alors abattage ou
non isolement ou non valorisation ou non
le débat est complexe et la seule lueur
d'espoir semble venir de la vaccination
or le vaccin malgré des essais
encourageants des laboratoires CEVA et
Boringer n'est toujours pas prêt les
laboratoires semblent un petit peu
réticents à investir massivement dans
une filière réputée de plus en plus
fragile monsieur le ministre pensez-vous
pouvoir mener une action forte en faveur
de la mise en place et du soutien de ce
programme de vaccination
merci chers collègues et pour vous
répondre monsieur Marc fenault ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur metdevielle vous
m'interrogez sur la question la grippe
aviaire qui est un sujet effectivement
de préoccupation de préoccupation et de
détresse pour nombre de producteurs
contenus de l'arrivée d'une deuxième une
vague épidémique puissante comme celle
que nous avons connue en 2022 d'abord
vous dire des éléments sur les mesures
de gestion qui ont été prises vous
l'avez rappelé face à la situation
sanitaire dégradée des mesures ont été
prises en particulier dans l'Ouest qui
est particulièrement touché en ce moment
elles ont été regardées avec l'ensemble
des filières que je remercie du travail
de collaboration qui est le nôtre sur
ces questions qui sont des questions
difficiles ici nous avons besoin de
renforcer des mesures parfois nous avons
besoin et nous pouvons les alléger nous
le faisons à chaque fois que c'est
possible c'est une concertation qui est
ajustée chaque semaine pour faire en
sorte de faire face à la difficulté des
filières deuxième élément vous avez
parlé la question des indemnisations
permettez-moi de dire j'ai un petit
point de désaccord avec vous sur le les
montants qui ont été déployés sur
l'année 2022 près d'un virgule un
milliard d'euros qui ont été déployés
sur un chiffre d'affaires global de 6,7
milliards d'euros je pense que si nous
n'avions pas été au rendez-vous de ces
mesures très puissantes la filière les
filières qui sont concernées dans votre
région comme dans beaucoup de régions de
France aurait tout simplement disparu
c'est vrai que nous sommes en mode
encore dégradé qui a un certain nombre
de repeuplements qui n'ont pas pu faire
parce que les lieux d'acouvrages ont
disparu enfin vous m'interrogez sur la
question de la vaccination d'abord vous
dire que c'est parce que la France a agi
que nous avons obtenu une
expérimentation et donc tout le monde
connaissait le calendrier le calendrier
c'est une expérimentation autorisation
obtenue en juin expérimentation démarrée
en août en particulier sur les palmipède
en France c'est 5 pays qui expérimentent
nous attendons la qualification de la
vaccination au tournant de l'hiver en
décembre et en janvier et sans plus
attendre sans connaître précisément
encore les résultats de ce vaccin nous
travaillons déjà un plan de vaccination
qui permettra effectivement de redonner
de la perspective à nos éleveurs gérer
l'urgence réfléchir au moyen et long
terme c'est bien ce que nous allons
faire et ça permettra aussi que les
laboratoires qui seront chargés de
produire ce vaccin puisse se mettre en
situation de le faire dans des
conditions de délais qui soit
raisonnables pour la saison évidemment
2023 et donc on est à l'oeuvre sur
l'urgence et aussi sur le moyen long
terme la vaccination étant l'un des
moyens mais pas le seul vous le savez
aussi bien que moi merci monsieur le
sénateur
merci chers collègues vous avez moins de
40 secondes pour répondre merci monsieur
le ministre pour ces réponses sur la
vaccination bon vous êtes conscient
vraiment de la fragilité aujourd'hui de
la filière donc je crois les aider à
tenir jusqu'à la campagne de 2023 on
peut se poser des questions sur
l'opportunité de certains abattages à
partir du moment où il interdiction de
transport je crois que toutes les
mesures qui iront en faveur de cette
filière pour la faire tenir seront les
bienvenus et nous attendons bien sûr des
bonnes nouvelles du côté de laboratoire
et si le gouvernement est en plus si on
peut vacciner de façon anticipée je
crois que ce sera parfait et très bien
venu
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à notre collectionnatrix madame
Laurence Garnier pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la première ministre madame
la ministre le 19 février 2020
a été pour vous un jour historique c'est
ce que vous avez déclaré en annonçant
tout sourire la fermeture effective de
Fessenheim
quelques mois avant le président de la
République avait annoncé sa volonté de
fermer 14 centrales nucléaires d'ici à
depuis vous avez réussi le double
exploit d'augmenter notre besoin en
électricité et de diminuer notre
production vous augmentez nos besoins en
achetant des voitures électriques à la
Chine et vous diminuez notre production
en s'abordant notre parc nucléaire par
vos changements de pieds successifs au
gré des arrivées et des départs des
ministres écologistes
madame la ministre la guerre en Ukraine
loin d'expliquer la crise actuelle n'a
fait que révéler vos propres
insuffisances et aujourd'hui ce sont les
Français qui vont devoir subir une
pénurie dont vous êtes responsable alors
on rouvre nos centrales à charbon
polluantes je pense accord de mai en
Loire-Atlantique dont l'affermiture n'en
finit pas d'être reportée et puis
surtout on prépare les Français au grand
bon en arrière en leur parlant fermeture
d'école délestage et baisse de tension
en moins de trois ans madame la Première
ministre en moins de trois ans vous avez
réussi à remplacer la stratégie
énergétique française par un catalogue
de bonnes pratiques de doudoune et de
col roulés alors madame la ministre
jusqu'à quand comptez-vous infantilisez
les français pour masquer votre
préparation et vos compromissions merci
pour vos réponses Monsieur Roland
Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Laurence Garnier je suis
doublement surpris de votre question
d'abord
d'abord parce que vous vous semblez
remettre en cause une stratégie de
développement énergétique qui dont nous
avons eu l'occasion de discuter ici au
Sénat dans le cadre d'un débat article
50-1 dans le cadre duquel j'avais eu
l'occasion de rappeler que la période
dans laquelle les centrales nucléaires
en France ont été le moins entretenus
conduisant du coup à un taux
d'occupation des centrales nucléaires le
plus faible historique c'était sous le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
j'aimerais pouvoir affirmer j'aimerais
pouvoir affirmer que face à un défi
historique celui de la décarbonation de
la France face à un défi historique et
la guerre aux portes de l'Europe et face
à un défi historique qui est oui de
restaurer la crédibilité de notre grand
opérateur national et de l'amener vers
l'avant le développement de nouveaux
réacteurs vous l'avez dit la fermeture
de centrales à charbon difficile dans
certains territoires comme le vôtre nous
soyons capables de créer de l'unité
nationale face à ça je regrette que nous
soyons dans la gestion des peurs face à
ça je regrette que nous soyons dans la
gestion de la caricature vous le savez
ce gouvernement est extrêmement mobilisé
de manière à éviter le pire le pire ce
serait des délaissages sur lesquels nous
travaillons jour et nuit avec
l'opérateur pour les éviter j'en appelle
à la responsabilité des Françaises et
des Français qui le savent et qui
réduisent aujourd'hui leur consommation
d'électricité pour faire face aux défis
j'aimerais que tout le monde soit aussi
responsable que les industriels français
aujourd'hui qui depuis des mois
réduisent leur consommation
d'électricité merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à présent à notre collègue monsieur le
sénateur Michel Laugier pour le groupe
Union centriste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question plutôt mes interrogations
s'adresse à Monsieur ministre de la
Santé à propos d'un sujet déjà évoqué en
début de séance au mois d'août dernier
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes subissait
une super attaque sans précédent samedi
soir c'est l'hôpital de Versailles qui a
été victime d'une attaque similaire une
cyberata que d'une telle ampleur qui a
eu des conséquences immédiates sur la
prise en charge des patients avec des
déprogrammations d'opérations et des
transferts vers d'autres hôpitaux
pendant peut-être encore plusieurs mois
le plus grand hôpital de soins des
Yvelines ne fonctionnera au ralenti
détériorant l'offre hospitalière et
l'accès aux soins de tout le département
confronter une crise majeure depuis
plusieurs années l'hôpital déjà au bord
de l'imposion et qui c'est à dire se met
des confrontés à l'affût de malade de
toucher par les épidémies de
bronchiolite covid et grippe doit
dorénavant faire face à des attaques
informatiques qui s'apparente ni plus ni
moins a du terrorisme comment cette
attaque va-t-elle pas pu être déjoué
alors qu'à la suite de plusieurs
tentatives on savait que cet hôpital
était visé comment cette cyberattaque a
été plus se produire après celle de
Corbeil-Essonnes visiblement aucun
enseignement d'analysé aujourd'hui les
patients les personnes les soignants
attendent de retour rapide à la normale
et la conclusion de l'enquête sur
l'identification des hackers où en
est-on plus généralement quel est le
degré de fragilité des administrations
françaises aux cyber terrorisme et
quelle est la doctrine de
gouvernementale face aux demandes de
rançon enfin quelle dispositif allez
vous mettre en place pour dissuader
toute nouvelle tentative de
déstabilisation de notre système
hospitalier et plus largement de nos
administrations merci
de la santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
des sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Laugier je l'ai dit cette attaque et
vous l'avez dit également est ignoble
elle tente de prendre en otage la santé
des Français tous nos hôpitaux plus
largement les administrations font face
à cette nouvelle menace cette
cybercriminalité qui cherche avant tout
à s'enrichir en s'en prenant à nos
infrastructures essentielles les
attaques malheureusement évoluent au fur
et à mesure que les moyens de protection
évoluent également pour protéger nos
établissements
vous avez parlé de rançon éventuel je le
redis à nouveau avec la plus grande
détermination nous ne céderons jamais en
ce qui concerne la santé des Français
bien entendu le problème est pris plus
qu'au sérieux j'ai rappelé des
financements dont nous avons mis en
place la coordination qu'il y a entre
les différents ministères à ce sujet à
ce jour 150 établissements et
groupements hospitaliers ont déjà
bénéficié sont accompagnés dans le cadre
du Plan parcours cybersécurité je tiens
surtout à rassurer nos concitoyens la
sécurité et la qualité des soins sont
toujours garanties effectivement il y a
une déprogrammation immédiate tant qu'on
ne connaissait pas l'ampleur de
l'attaque il y a eu également je vous le
confirme mercredi 6 transferts au total
à titre préventif pour faire de la place
au cas où trois enfants et trois adultes
vers les autres hôpitaux de l'île de
France en particulier la PHP que je
salue ici
en attendant le traitement des patients
admis se poursuit bien entendu avec un
mode papier et en étant obligé de se
déplacer d'un service à l'autre en
particulier en ce qui concerne
l'imagerie et la biologie médicale mais
en tout état de cause notre capacité à
assurer la sécurité et la continuité des
soins est essentielle bien sûr pour
protéger nos concitoyens mais aussi pour
diminuer l'emprise des pirates en
diminuant l'attractivité de nos
établissements la stratégie elle est
donc globale prévenir les cyberattaques
bien entendu en renforçant de plus en
plus les moyens de protection des
établissements mais aussi limiter
l'impact de ces attaques pour rendre je
le disais aux établissements moins
attractifs vous parliez des épidémies
qui tapent l'hôpital j'en profite juste
très rapidement pour rappeler dans cet
assemblée l'importance de la vaccination
et du port de masque en endroit clos je
vous remercie merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez une poignée de seconde chers
collègues pour répondre si vous le
souhaitez une poignée
il y a quelques semaines dans cette
émission qu'il a une question sur la
sécurité le ministre de l'Intérieur
m'avait dit et à la fin c'est toujours
la police qui gagne le problème c'est
qu'on ne voit jamais la fin
merci cher collègue la parole est à
présent au sénateur Pierre ouzulias pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
septembre 2020 le président de la
République célébrait la France comme le
pays des Lumières et de l'innovation et
railler ceux qui préférait le modèle
amis chez le retour à la lampe à huile
cet hiver la France des Lumières va
basculer en mode amis chez s'éclairer à
la lampe à l'huile et à la bougie
notre notre pays qui était exportateur
d'électricité il y a peu va maintenant
dépendre de ses voisins pour tenter de
continuer à alimenter en électricité ces
transports ces services publics ces
industries ces entreprises etc comment
a-t-on pu en arriver là comment la
septième puissance économique mondiale
est-elle plus devenir en si peu de temps
un pays en voie de sous-développement
ces pénuries vont rappeler aux
générations les plus anciennes les
privations de la prière les tickets de
rationnement elle frappe d'effroi les
plus jeunes qui prennent ainsi
conscience du dix classement inéluctable
de notre pays
que les turifères de la décroissance se
réjouissent nous y allons à grands pas
la start-up nation n'a plus de jus
dans la France en pénurie comme dans le
Radeau de la Méduse le gouvernement en
est réduit à tirer à la Courtepaille
ceux qui vont être sacrifiés et comme
dans la chanson ce sont les plus jeunes
qui ont été choisis ainsi comme vous
nous l'avez annoncé dans cette hémicycle
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale les écoles pourront être
privées électricité mais nous sommes
rassurés les parents seront prévenus par
le préfet la veille à 19 heures
la crise pandémique a durement touché
toute la genèse de la maternelle à
l'université monsieur le ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour qu'elle ne soit
pas de nouveau la victime de politique
qui les ignore monsieur le ministre
préservé notre jeunesse
merci chers collègues
la parole est donnée à Monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs les
sénatrices
merci pour cet accueil
et monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question
je pense qu'aujourd'hui
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure avec un ton
particulier peut-être lié à celui de la
question qui m'avait été adressée mais
je souhaiterais vraiment vraiment
sincèrement et solennellement
en appeler à la mobilisation générale
aujourd'hui nous le savons nous faisons
face tous et toutes à une guerre aux
portes de l'Europe aujourd'hui nous
faisons nous le savons face à un défi de
production de la part de notre opérateur
national et je voudrais saluer à la fois
le nouveau PDG l'ucrémont et à travers
lui l'ensemble des salariés d'EDF qui se
mobilisent jour et nuit pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse comme il nous le dit
livrer des watts
et oui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il se peut que dans des cas
extrêmement particuliers dans un dans un
environnement climatique extrêmement
particulier on puisse mettre en place
des délaissages ciblés ça a été affirmé
et mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
et monsieur le sénateur vous le savez le
plan de prévention a été extrêmement
calibrée l'application Ecowatt permet de
prévenir ces délestages bien en avant je
vous le dis et je vous le répète au cas
où la météo deviendrait orange ou rouge
chacun d'entre nous doit faire les
efforts pour limiter sa consommation
et au cas où très peu probable les
écoles viendraient à en être affectés je
l'ai confirmé avec mon collègue de
l'éducation nationale ce sont bien trois
jours auparavant que les parents en
seront prévenus
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
sénatrices pour éviter le pire le
meilleur c'est quand même de s'y
préparer
nous y sommes prêts nous l'éviterons
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
Madame Jacqueline Eustache brignot pour
le groupe des Républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre armé de machettes coupe ou
simplement de tesson de bouteille des
jeunes livres même font régner un climat
de terreur dans le 101e département
français
bande violence alcool main coupée guerre
de gang caillassage de voiture de police
la liste est longue de tous les fléaux
que subissent les maorets depuis
longtemps livré à eux-mêmes des milliers
de jeunes mineurs isolés sans papiers
peuple de bidonvilles à Mayotte sans
avenir ces jeunes hors-la-loi n'ont rien
à perdre et menace la société tout
entière
infernal n'est pas près de s'arrêter
puisque sous la pression migratoire la
maternité de Mamoudzou est débordée tout
comme le bureau des titres de séjour on
envoie le raid pour calmer la situation
mais il faudrait davantage du moyen pour
mettre fin à cette erreur la politique
du pansement ne suffit plus la vie de
tous les mahorets en danger par cette
immigration incontrôlée nous ne pouvons
pas accepter d'offrir un tel avenir aux
habitants de Mayotte qui ont fait le
choix de la France Monsieur Darmanin va
se rendre à Mayotte à la fin du mois
pouvez-vous nous garantir que les soins
qui seront formulés pour 2023 ne seront
pas des vœux pieux serez-vous en mesure
de garantir aux habitants de cette île
le respect des lois est principe de la
République française en dénonçant
clairement les causes de ce désordre et
de cette ultra-violence
merci chers collègues j'appelle Monsieur
Jean-François carinco ministre délégué
chargé des outre-mer pour vous répondre
[Musique]
effectivement
vous l'avez dit ces actes sont
inacceptables
la mobilisation
du ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outre-mer et total vous
vous prenez vous connaissez les moyens
qui sont mis en œuvre au moins
reconnaissez-le monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur se rend à Mayotte en
décembre il confirmera les engagements
qui sont pris
s'agissant de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine je voudrais
simplement dire que 24 000 étrangers en
situation irrégulière ont été reconduits
à la frontière l'an passé soit 78% de
plus qu'en 2020
324 passeurs
324 passeurs ont été présentés à justice
4 filières ont été démantelés la loi sur
l'immigration qui sera présentée bientôt
au Parlement
la loi qui sera présentée au Parlement
répondra à un certain nombre de vos
demandes j'en suis sûr mais ce qui
compte mais ceux qui comptent que vous
passez sous silence c'est l'effort
extraordinaire que Madame la première
minis sera autorisée monsieur Darmanin
et moi-même un maître en œuvre sur le
développement sur le développement
est-ce que vous savez que 83 millions
d'euros sont dépensés en 2023 sur
l'éducation nationale est-ce que vous
savez que j'ai signé un contrat de 411
millions d'euros sur l'eau avec le haut
de Mayotte est-ce que vous savez que
Monsieur le Ministre braon y a été et a
été ahuri des efforts faits en
innovation sur la matière de santé en
matière de développement économique ce
que vous dites madame la sénatrice ce
que vous dites est une j'allais dire une
insulte aux élus de Mayotte qui eux se
mobilisent
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez 33
secondes pour répliquer chers collègues
alors réponse très facile très facile
monsieur mise le préfet du département
estime que si on ne fait rien il y aura
750 000 habitants à Mayotte en 2050 ils
sont aujourd'hui 300000 alors Monsieur
ministre êtes-vous prêt à entendre que
le droit du sol que les politiques
publiques en matière d'accès aux soins
gratuits et à la scolarisation des
enfants doit être
drastiquement pardon remis en cause sur
ce rituel sur ce tiroir je rappelle que
80% des enfants scolarisés à Mayotte ne
sont pas des enfants de Lille donc ce
sont des appels d'air considérable à
l'immigration de l'île qui déstabilise
cette île en permanence que s'est-il
passé concrètement depuis votre
déplacement en août 2022 collègues
monsieur le ministre rien je voudrais
juste finir et triste
la parole juste à présent Monsieur
Jacques Bernard manié pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
S et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire des tâches chargée de la
jeunesse et du service national service
national universel madame la ministre
votre budget 2023 attribue 140 millions
d'euros au service national universel
les centres des crédits dérisoire pour
les autres dispositifs du soutien à la
vie associative et pourtant nous savons
tous ici que le service national
universel est un échec depuis sa
création en 2019 en 2022 vous vouliez 50
000 jeunes comme les années précédentes
nous vous avions fait part de notre
scepticisme et au final ce sont
seulement 32000 services qui seront
réalisés
il est évident que les jeunes n'adhèrent
pas à ce projet imaginé promu et soutenu
par le Président de la République qui
doit rester aujourd'hui le seul
convaincu de son intérêt et malgré cela
vous augmentez encore ce budget pour
2023 inscrivant 140 millions en espérant
64000 jeunes 27% d'augmentation pendant
que les crédits du service civique
progressent moins que l'inflation alors
que c'est un outil très pertinent pour
les jeunes et qui aujourd'hui est très
recherchée vous le savez madame la
ministre la généralisation du SNU a une
classe d'âge sera très difficile autant
pour des raisons budgétaires que pour
des raisons d'adhésion madame la
ministre il faut savoir tirer les leçons
d'un échec d'autres solutions existent
pour l'éducation et la citoyenneté de
notre jeunesse pourquoi ne pas soutenir
vraiment le développement du service
civique ainsi que les colonies de
vacances vrai lieu de mixité et de
socialisation dès le plus jeune âge et
promouvoir le BAFA qui pourrait faire
partie le parcours d’engagement et de
citoyenneté qui se déploraient à bien
moindre coût en apportant un vrai
soutien à la vie associative dans notre
pays madame la ministre aujourd'hui on
attend vos propositions votre ministère
répondra-t-il enfin aux aspirations et
aux besoins de notre jeunesse merci
chers
beaucoup madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
rapporteur manier j'ai la conviction que
nous ambitionnons la même chose pour nos
jeunesses c'est à dire une jeunesse qui
à goût en l'avenir qui est formé qui a
de l'espérance et pour ça monsieur le
sénateur aucune opposition entre les
dispositifs le service civique augmente
il a même il y a même plus de missions
et d'agrément que de jeunes fassent aux
missions proposées plus que jamais nous
avons investi sur le service civique les
colonies de vacances l'éducation
populaire augmente vacances apprenante
un million de jeunes létés encore
dernier le BAFA installation du comité
de filière BAFA financement massif avec
plus de 200 euros pour chaque jeune qui
le souhaitent pour lever le pour lever
le frein financier monsieur le sénateur
à aucun moment ni dans votre esprit ni
dans le mien nous opposons les
dispositifs de nos jeunesses par contre
qui est certain c'est qu'il est
nécessaire de construire un parcours de
citoyenneté il ne se décrète pas nous
avons aujourd'hui une jeunesse qui pour
une partie d'entre elles est nous avons
besoin d'unités de bilan de santé un
parcours qui fait que notre abstention
recule nous avons besoin d'une jeunesse
qui retrouve la culture de la défense
nous avons besoin d'une jeunesse formée
aux gestes qui sauvent nous avons besoin
d'une jeunesse à qui on propose un
projet pour elle d'abord qui l'a fait
grandir en complémentarité du projet
pédagogique de l'éduc de l'éducation
civique et morale mais nous avons aussi
besoin d'une jeunesse qui s'engage et
votre famille politique monsieur le
sénateur porte ses engagements qu'ils
soient civils ou militaires alors avec
le ministre de l'éducational le mystère
de la le ministre de des armées sous
l'autorité de la première ministre nous
déployons avec beaucoup d'apprentissage
année après année un grand projet pour
notre jeunesse dans laquelle nous
investissons parce que un pays fort un
pays uni doit préparer sa jeunesse à
répondre au défi de notre temps le
premier guerre en Ukraine aujourd'hui
défi climatique majeur comment les
formes face aux catastrophes naturelles
et puis enfin monsieur le sénateur un
pays uni c'est une jeunesse qui se parle
et qui partagent des et pour ça il faut
qu'elle se rencontre le SMU c'est pour
c'est pour eux c'est pour les autres et
c'est pour la France je vous remercie
madame la ministre
vous avez 8 secondes pour répondre chers
collègues
vous venez de rappeler sur la
citoyenneté toutefois vous n'avez pas
répondu sur ma question du service
civique du service national universel
allez vous continuer allez vous le
réformer allez vous modifier sa façon de
se développer
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue sénateur Monsieur Alain Cadec
pour le groupe des Républicains
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé du Commerce extérieur
tout indique que la Commission
européenne va initier rapidement le
processus de conclusion formelle de
l'accord commercial entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur et de le faire
sur une bâche juridique qui prévoit une
décision à la majorité simple au conseil
après approbation du Parlement européen
sans aucune implication des parlements
nationaux
la France a longtemps justifié son
opposition à cet accord en invoquant
l'insuffisance des engagements pris par
le Brésil du président bolsonaro en
matière d'action climatique et de lutte
contre la déforestation mais de ce point
de vue l'élection récente du président
Lula change la donne et ouvre la voie à
la jonction d'une annexe
environnementale à l'accord contenant
les garanties exigées par l'union de la
part du Brésil
l'Allemagne d'une part et le Brésil
d'autre part ont de grands intérêts dans
l'affaire la première pour doper ces
exportations industrielles vers Amérique
latine le second pour obtenir un accès
préférentiel au marché agricole de
l'Union il pousse donc l'un et l'autre
pour faire en sorte que l'accord puisse
entrer en vigueur dès le début de
l'année prochaine dans ces conditions
monsieur le ministre
que compte faire la France pour
s'opposer à un accord dramatique pour
nos intérêts agricoles sachant qu'un
blocage français à Bruxelles ne pourra
bientôt plus être justifiée seulement
par des arguments environnementaux et
qu'il ne sera de toute façon plus
possible techniquement compte tenu de
lavage juridique retenue par la
commission merci
et des Français de l'étranger merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cadec oui vous avez raison
l'élection du président Lula est une
bonne nouvelle pour la relation
bilatérale entre la France et le Brésil
et le président de la République a salué
comme tel
oui l'accord du Mercosur est en
négociation depuis l'année 2000 ça fait
donc 22 ans que cet accord est en
négociation entre l'Union européenne et
le Brésil et il n'est à ce jour ni
finalisé ni signé et à fortiori
paratifié la France a posé des
conditions très claires pour la
conclusion de cet accord elles sont de
trois ordres la première c'est la
question de la déforestation il y a lieu
de saluer d'ailleurs la conclusion
avant-hier dans le cadre du trilogue
européen du Règlement sur la
déforestation il est hors de question
d'importer qui a un seul kilo de bœuf
produit élevés qui a sur de la prairie
qui aurait été gagné qui a en rasant la
forêt amazonienne pas plutôt d'ailleurs
que tout autre produit la deuxième
conclusion et la deuxième condition
derrière la déforestation c'est le
respect toutes les politiques publiques
des pays membres du Mercosur des accords
de Paris et la troisième condition c'est
le respect de l'ensemble des normes
sanitaires et environnementales de
l'Union européenne et c'est donc dans ce
cadre-là que les négociations se
poursuivent le jour où elles auront
abouti et je dis bien le jour où elles
auront abouti la France examinera cet
accord et se prononcera dans le cadre de
la procédure européenne au sein du
Conseil de l'Union européenne et le
Parlement sera évidemment saisi par le
Mans européen dans le cadre de ses
pouvoirs ou les ou les parlements
nationaux si les accords devaient être
scindés je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le minier chers collègues vous avez 35
secondes pour répliquer que la
Commission européenne elle est utilisée
l'article 207 du traité et elle ne
consultera pas les parlements nationaux
cela étant certains députés européens
Renaissance dans une lettre au
commissaire d'ombrowski
on prétendu que la procédure choisie par
la commission n'était illégal c'est pas
vrai elle n'est pas illégale elle est
parfaitement légale et compte tenu de la
probation requise du Parlement européen
elle ne peut être qualifiée d'outrage
démocratique donc monsieur le ministre
la France est en grande difficulté sur
ce dossier et surtout nos agriculteurs
merci
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
madame la sénatrice Annick Jacquemet
pour le groupe Union centriste merci
madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la Santé le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran est intervenu
ce matin à la télévision sur le problème
de la tension sur les stocks de
doliprane il a tenté de rassurer nos
concitoyens en expliquant que la France
n'était pas seule concernée que la
tension était mondiale peut-être mais
elle dure depuis quelques temps et
touche maintenant les enfants début
novembre notre collègue Bruno Belin
soulevait déjà le problème vous avez
alors répondu prendre la mesure de la
situation et vouloir augmenter le volume
des stocks et les moyens d'alerte
aujourd'hui c'est le doliprane
pédiatrique qui pose problème alors que
le froid est arrivé et avec lui les
épidémies saisonnières nous sommes en
rupture l'impact est particulièrement
problématique car pour le traitement des
enfants le doliprane et le médicament de
première intention il n'existe aucun
substitut d'après l'Agence nationale de
sûreté du fréquemment l'ibuprofène et
l'inspirine leur sont contre-indiqués le
principal fabricant Sanofi en situation
de quasi monopole avec 98% des parts de
marché sur la présentation pédiatrique
est en grande difficulté aucun
concurrent ne peut supplier à la baisse
de sa production toujours selon landsm
ces tensions pourraient encore durer
plusieurs semaines on ne peut pas
laisser les choses en l'état car outre
les difficultés posées en ambulatoire
par ses pénuries l'effet domino sera
inévitable de plus en plus d'enfants
seront orientés vers les hôpitaux en
particulier les services d'urgence alors
qu'ils sont déjà saturés monsieur le
ministre à court terme comment votre
gouvernement tant il garantir que nos
enfants ne manqueront pas de doliprane
pédiatrique cet hiver à plus long terme
comment comptez-vous éviter que de
telles situations ne se reproduisent je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues pour vous répondre
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
jacquemais je vous prie d'abord
d'excuser le ministre de la Santé qui
comme la vue comme vous l'avez vu à du
sable santé et c'est donc le ministre de
l'Industrie qui vous répond qui vous
répond d'abord que cette pénurie vous
l'avez dit est mondiale elle est liée à
une volatilité de la consommation de
médicaments général et de paracétamol en
particulier extrêmement importante liée
à la crise de la covid qui a modifié de
manière importante évidemment les
comportements de consommation à la
distribution entre la ville et l'hôpital
la France a réagi parmi les plus
rapidement liés à un système d'alerte
qui s'appelle transmettre qui nous a
permis d'identifier ces tensions réelles
que vous mentionnez très tôt qui nous a
permis de prendre des décisions
notamment
l'interdiction d'exportation le passage
privilégié par les grossistes
répartiteurs qui permettent d'assurer du
mieux possible la distribution dans les
pharmacies mais qui vous l'avez dit dans
certains cas particuliers n'empêche pas
certaines pharmacies mais j'insiste bien
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui face à nous
pas eu une pénurie de doliprane quel
qu'il soit d'ailleurs mais c'est dans
certaines pharmacies il est vrai que le
doliprane dont vous mentionnez l'absence
est vient à manquer et donc un
évidemment j'engage les patients qui
cherchent du doliprane pour les enfants
aujourd'hui malheureusement à chercher
dans plusieurs pharmacies de nous nous
faisons confirmer par les
industriels que le défi majeur pour ce
doliprane on savait ce paracétamol
pardon dans mon savait qu'il est
distribué dans des flacons contrairement
à d'autres des enjeux sont
essentiellement liés au fournisseur de
flacons et de verre sur lequel on me dit
que la situation s'améliore et donc
votre réponse de court terme c'est ça
s'améliore cherchez dans les pharmacies
attenantes mais on va se sortir du
problème à moyen terme évidemment vous
le savez l'enjeu majeur c'est de
relocaliser nous le faisons nous avons
un projet d'usine importante de
publication de production pardon de
doliprane à Grenoble c'est l'entreprise
séquence qui ne produira et donc pas
l'entreprise que vous je connais
monsieur le sénateur mais nous
travaillons pour que à nouveau la France
soit un terrain de production de
consommation et pourquoi pas
d'exportation à jour de médicaments
merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
présent à notre collègue madame la
sénatrice Annick Pétrus pour le groupe
des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
la direction générale des douanes et des
doigts indirects jouent au rôle
profondérant dans la sécurité des
Français en effet les douanes sont entre
autres nature de la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants elles sont ainsi à
l'origine de 60 à 80% de saisie de
stupéfiants sur le territoire national
de plus si le rôle de la douane de la
lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiant est
encore trop souvent sous-estimé il est
pourtant amené à se renforcer ce trafic
est resté dynamique et à peu souffert de
la crise sanitaire la menace liée au
trafic de stupéfiants ne cesse de
s'accroître augmentation des flux et des
saisies
os de la criminalité connexe
vulnérabilité de nos ports et aéroports
la consommation demeure également très
élevée souvent un vrai enjeu de santé
publique la situation apparaît désormais
critique en France du fait des multiples
voies d'entrée sur le territoire trafic
maritime en provenance d'Amérique du Sud
mais aussi échange terrestre avec les
pays frontaliers frais postal et express
dans l'ensemble du monde nos territoires
ultramarins comme Saint-Martin sont donc
particulièrement vulnérables ils doivent
faire l'objet d'une attention spécifique
du fait de leur situation géographique à
la croisée d'importantes route maritimes
et aérienne vers l'Union européenne
Saint-Martin je vous le rappelle se
situe bel et bien au sein du territoire
douanier communauté malheureusement
aujourd'hui sur mon territoire
nous ne bénéficiions d'aucune protection
face à cette trafic faute d'effectif
avec seulement deux douaniers à ce jour
en poste sur l'île c'est un effectif
clairement insignifiant pour un
territoire de près de 53 km2 est une
zone économique exclusive de près de 300
km². alors ma question est simple allez
vous laisser la France ouverte à toutes
sortes de trafic car voyez-vous monsieur
le ministre Saint-Martin c'est aussi la
France je vous remercie
merci chers collègues pour vous répondre
Monsieur Jean-François Carenco ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer
madame la chaînette madame la sénatrice
vous savez le problème n'est pas
spécifique à saint-martin-saint-barth
ni aux îles de la Caraïbe le trafic de
drogue est partout et le trafic de
drogue le gouvernement essaye de lutter
partout notamment en Guyane où je me
rends à la demande du ministre de
l'Intérieur la semaine prochaine c'est
une priorité du milieu intérieur qui
s'est rendu en Guyane notamment et à la
Martinique mais qui a évoqué l'ensemble
des sujets de la Caraïbe avec Monsieur
Attal le ministre en charge des douanes
avec Monsieur le Ministre de la Justice
ne doutez pas que globalement ce sujet
est pris en compte par le gouvernement
dans la pratique dans la pratique ça
veut dire qu'il nous faut coordonner
l'action de l'État en mer sur l'autorité
du préfet de zone de la Martinique les
travaux sont en cours entre l'ensemble
des administrations sur l'autorité de la
première ministre globalement cela veut
dire que j'ai demandé pour Saint-Martin
pardon spécifiquement
un monsieur Attal de renforcer à
Saint-Barth à Saint-Martin les postes de
douane qui ont disparu il est vrai il y
a quelques années la discussion est en
cours avec le ministre en charge des
douanes nous avons vous le savez et vous
voyez ce bateau tel qu'il est récemment
mis en œuvre une un bateau des douanes
j'en avais jamais vu d'aussi gros et il
est désormais et il est désormais
complètement à la manœuvre donc ne
doutez pas monsieur le ministre Attal
répondra j'en suis sûr favorablement à
votre demande je lui en ai parlé encore
il y a quelques jours
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à présent à Monsieur le testeur
jean-Pierre Sueur pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Kester merci madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
la surpopulation dans les prisons à
atteint un niveau que nous n'avions
jamais connu il y a aujourd'hui
1350 personnes qui sont dans des
cellules où il y a 3 détenus et qui
dorment sur des matelas par terre et la
situation est telle que la France a été
condamnée pour indignité par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ma
question est très simple monsieur le
garde des sceaux qu'allez-vous faire
par rapport à cette situation dans les
mois qui viennent
et à Monsieur
Eric garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice merci Madame
et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur monsieur
ça n'est pas la première fois que vous
me posez la question
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que c'est
la démonstration cette surpopulation
carcérale que ni la politique pénale que
je conduis sous l'égide de madame la
Première ministre ni la justice
contrairement à ce que certains disent
en permanence né laxiste deuxièmement
vous le savez vous n'êtes pas le seul à
être préoccupé par la question j'ai
porté avec beaucoup de force la
proposition
sénatoriale de monsieur le Président
buffet sur les conditions indignes
quelles sont les leviers que nous avons
et je voudrais vous dire d'ailleurs que
c'est une gageure de répondre à cette
question aussi complexe en deux minutes
mais quels sont les leviers rénovation
d'abord et de ce point de vue je
voudrais vous dire sans triomphalisme
que vous consacriez par en 70 millions
d'euros aux rénovation nous consacrons
plus de 170 millions par an en
rénovation construction de places de
prison 15000 places elles seront
construites je le dis nous en avons la
moitié en 2024 et nous continuons 15000
places mais ensuite il y a bien sûr
rappelé au procureur généraux la loi
bloc Pen ce que je fais dans toutes mes
circulaires mais également bien sûr
développer les peines alternatives
notamment le travail d'intérêt général
lutter contre la récidive j'étais hier
avec le sénateur Bourgine nous avons
inauguré une SAS structure
d'accompagnement à la sortie c'est un
établissement pénitentiel mais c'est
aussi une structure qui permet d'éviter
la récidive et bien sûr la prévention ce
matin j'ai reçu la délégation du la
délégation du droit des femmes du Sénat
qui m'a remis un rapport absolument
extraordinaire sur la pornographie et ce
rapport elle mérite de mettre cela dans
le débat public des enfants de 11 ans
c'est la moyenne d'âge ont taxé
librement à la pornographie et bien
lutter contre ça efficacement c'est
naturellement lutter contre la
délinquance et si aussi régler la
question de la surpopulation carcérale
merci Monsieur le gardeesso monsieur le
Kester vous avez un peu plus d'une
minute pour répliquer si vous le
souhaitez
sur le garde des sceaux je ne vous ai
pas interrogé sur la pornographie qui
est en effet un fléau
monsieur le garde des sceaux j'espère
que vous avez lu le rapport des états
généraux de la justice qui a été remis
qui vous a été remis par Monsieur
Jean-Marc Sauvé vous lirez dans ce
rapport que depuis 30 ans on construit
des prisons et la surpopulation de
décroît pas pour autant oui et le
rapport dit que la réponse n'est pas
essentiellement là mais la réponse elle
est dans une régulation le mot est dans
le rapport simplement cette régulation
il faut la pensée la réfléchir avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés et nous
aimerions que vous vous pensiez
là-dessus sur la mise en oeuvre de cette
régulation ce que pour le moment vous ne
faites pas alors vous dites comme
toujours que c'est la faute à avant
qu'on connaît et qu'il faut des peines
alternatives l'aménagement des peines
etc mais on ne sent pas la volonté de
répondre au jugement qui condamne la
France parce que l'indiquité elle est
réelle dans un certain nombre de nos
prisons
150% de surpopulation dans 36 d'entre
elles et si on n'agit pas
fortement dans ce sens et bien on ne
prépare pas la réinsertion car cet état
d'indignité dans les prisons c'est ce
qui fait qu'il n'y a pas de réinsertion
et donc résidus
la parole est à présent à monsieur
Guillaume chevrolier pour le groupe des
Républicains monsieur le sénateur vous
avez deux minutes merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au Premier ministre
après la cop27 sur le climat qui n'a pas
été satisfaisante la COP 15 sur la
diversité biologique est ouverte depuis
hier apportant avec elle l'espoir d'un
possible accord ambitieux permettant
d'enrayer le déclin de la biodiversité
nous le souhaitons tous ici tant le
Sénat immobilisé sur les questions de
biodiversité et de climats qui sont liés
je salue d'ailleurs l'accord européen
qui vient d'être trouvé sur
l'interdiction d'importation des
produits liés à la déforestation un
enjeu majeur pointé par la Chambre haute
cette COP15 instaure indéniablement un
dialogue utile entre les gouvernements
en lien avec les citoyens et les
entreprises face au taux d'extinction
des espèces supérieures de 100 à 1000
fois le taux naturel avec des
populations de vertébrés qui ont chuté
de 69 % en moins de 50 ans aujourd'hui
plus de 1 million d'espèces animales et
végétales sont menacés à court terme
c'est donc une sur 8
cette perte massive de biodiversité a
des conséquences directes sur notre
économie et concerne de nombreux
secteurs l'agriculture avec le déclin
des pollinisateurs la pêche avec la
surexploitation et le blanchiment des
coraux ainsi que le tourisme impacté par
les paysages en souffrance sans oublier
l'eau le sujet est à la fois
international mais il est profondément
local nos collectivités les élus ont à
cœur de protéger leur territoire la
diplomatie environnementale ne peut pas
tout régler nous devons continuer
d'accompagner nos collectivités et de
protéger ce sur quoi nous avons une
emprise réelle par des solutions fondées
sur la nature alors notre pays souhaite
porter un message d'exemplarité à
l'international la France nation verte
doit se prémunir d'avoir le verbe eau et
l'action faible donc madame la Première
ministre quels engagements concrets la
France porte-t-elle au niveau
international et qu'en est-il de
l'objectif 0 perte nette de biodiversité
inscrit dans la loi française
merci chers collègues la parole est tac
monsieur Christophe bechut ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires merci madame la
présidente madame mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateurs
Chevrier j'aimerais vous remercie pour
votre question mais pas seulement pour
votre présence il y a quelques jours au
sein du ministère de la transition
écologique pour y représenter le Sénat
français pour témoigner de votre
attachement à ce que cette COP15 soit un
succès quand avec Bérengère Couillard
nous avons reçu toutes les ONG qui sont
mobilisées et je sais que vous serez
personnellement un des acteurs de cette
de cette COP15 qui qui a commencé à
Montréal il y a quelques heures
elle est simple
vous allez donner les chiffres et ils
font froid dans le dos un million
d'espèces menacées 75% de la surface de
la planète qui est altérée par la
pollution
85% des zones humides qui ont disparu et
ce constat-là il nécessite une
mobilisation qui est à la hauteur de ces
extinctions de ces menaces en opposant
pas le climat et la biodiversité parce
que les deux sont liés quand le climat
des règles il accélère la disparition
des espèces il diminue ce que la forêt
est capable de piéger en termes de
carbone et à l'inverse quand on investit
sur des solutions qui sont fondées sur
la nature on se donne les moyens de
lutter contre les dérèglement climatique
nous allons à cette COP15 à la tête
d'une coalition de 112 pays avec le
Costa Rica et l'Angleterre pour définir
et pour défendre le 30-30 la
préservation de 30% des terres de 30%
des mers à l'horizon 2030 avec des
engagements financiers nous sommes un
des trois seuls pays pour le moment
avoir indiqué que nous étions prêts à
nous engager et avec une cohérence liée
à la fois à l'annonce d'un one forest
Summit dans quelques mois avec les pays
africains pour regarder comment
préserver le bassin du Congo et ses
réserves de biodiversité avec le refus
exprimé par le Président de la
République d'exploitation des fonds
sous-marins et avec la perspective de la
planification écologique portée par la
première ministre qui nous permettra de
relier tout ça et à court terme ce sont
150 millions d'euros
consacrés à la biodiversité qui pourront
être dégagées dans le cadre du fond vert
je salue la sénatrice l'avare dont je
sais l'attachement et le suivi attentif
par rapport à ce sujet et qui ne
permettront d'accompagner de manière
concrète nos territoires les 1756
territoires concernés par température à
2000 et la centaine de parcs nationaux
maritime ou régionaux dont nous
disposons merci pour votre question
monsieur le ministre vous avez une
poignée de seconde pour répliquer oui
merci monsieur le ministre nous
soutenons les 30% des reprotégés mais on
veut une fictivité réelle et le fond
vert ne suffira pas de nom vraiment les
moyens d'avoir notre souveraineté
notamment sur nos
territoriales et notamment d'outre-mer
merci chers collègues la parole est
à Madame Brigitte l'herbier sénatrice
dans le groupe les républicains
madame la présidente madame le
méniscobel chers collègues
l'UNICEF a rendu dernièrement un rapport
très inquiétant sur la protection de
l'enfance en France elle constate qu'un
enfant est tué par ses parents tous les
5 jours et que les hospitalisations pour
violence physique commise par les
parents ont augmenté de 50% de 2017 à
2020 la police la gendarmerie les
procureurs nous font régulièrement état
de cette violence intrafamiliale
particulièrement grave pendant le
confinement le secrétaire d'État Adrien
taquet de l'époque était très attentif
et inquiet pour l'avenir les violences
faites aux femmes sont désormais
combattues avec véhémence par tous c'est
devenu une priorité nationale et c'est
parfait mais qu'en est-il pour la
maltraitance envers les enfants
si la situation de crise que traverse
l'aide sociale à l'enfance est très
préoccupant nationalement notamment par
le nombre important de mineurs étrangers
isolés elle l'est aussi dans mon
département du Nord qui est le premier
département français en nombre d'enfants
placés
50% des décisions du juge des enfants
concernent les mesures de protection de
l'enfance la presse locale souligne
toutes les semaines des situations
préoccupantes ou les professionnels du
secteur tirent la sonnette d'alarme
actuellement dans le Nord 270
ordonnances de placement ne peuvent être
honorés faute de place d'hébergement
pour ses enfants en détresse il reste
exposé au danger qu'il les menacent chez
eux
le rapport de l'Unicef est un nouveau
signal d'alarme un véritable plan
national de protection de l'enfant hors
de son foyer et de veille à domicile
doit être mise en place par le
gouvernement pourraient épauler les
départements une stratégie nationale et
nécessaire pour assurer une protection
renforcée c'est un devoir de solidarité
nationale apporté au département
submergé par la précarité des familles
l'afflux des mineurs isolés et surtout
par la violence rencontrer dans tous les
coins de France merci chers collègues
pour vous répondre madame Charlotte
cobel secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'enfance merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrice madame et sénatrice Brigitte
l'herbier oui le dispositif de
protection de l'enfance est en tension
oui les signaux de sortie de crise
sanitaire sont particulièrement rouges
vif tant sur les violences commises sur
les enfants que sur la santé mentale de
nos enfants que sur le nombre de
placements qui en forte augmentation
plus de 10% sur le département du Nord
comme dans bien d'autres départements et
dans des territoires particulièrement
impactés par les conditions sociaux
économiques en dépit vous l'avez rappelé
madame la triste de ce qui a été fait
dans le précédent quinquennat et en
dépit de l'investissement très fort qui
est fait par les départements sur cette
politique prioritaire c'est pourquoi le
président de la République et le
gouvernement ont décidé de faire de
l'enfance et de la protection de
l'enfance une priorité du quinquennat et
à l'occasion du dernier comité
interministériel qui s'est tenu autour
de la première ministre 40 actions 50
priorités ont été définies tous les
ministères sont engagés et j'en assuré
la coordination il m'appartient aussi
madame la sonatrice de mettre en oeuvre
la loi du 7 février 2022 vous en
conviendrez adopter relativement
récemment et qui impose une arme forte
impulsion le Gyproc enfance protégé
permettra une meilleure coordination des
acteurs au niveau national les conseils
départementaux de protection de
l'enfance permettront une action mais
une au niveau territorial il faut plus
d'états pas que l'État mais aux côtés
des départements c'est le rôle de ces
comités départementaux qui seront
installés à partir du 1er janvier dans
les départements prioritaires le
président du Nord m'a dit qu'il
installerait ce comité départemental
reste bien sûr évidemment la question
très complexe des hommes et des femmes
qui prennent en charge ses enfants vous
savez que la politique de revalorisation
des travailleurs sociaux est une
priorité du gouvernement nous sommes
mobilisés nous sommes tous mobilisés sur
la prise en charge des publics les plus
vulnérables pour les protéger pour les
accompagner pour leur assurer un avenir
et renforcer l'égalité des chances c'est
notre priorité vous pouvez compter sur
mon engagement merci Madame la Ministre
la parole est à présent monsieur
Jean-Louis Masson pour la pour les non
inscrits pardon
Madame le Ministre
étant tout aussi étant aussi grande que
deux fois la Belgique la région Grand
Est ne permet aucune gestion de
proximité de plus elle étouffe
l'ancienne région Alsace dont l'identité
est très forte tous les sondages
montrent qu'une écrasante majorité des
Alsaciens souhaite sortir du Grand est
malheureusement les membres de
l'exécutif régional s'accrochent à leur
pré-bendes et prétendent le contraire
le sujet du Grand est inévitablement
évoqué lors de l'examen du prochain
projet de loi de différenciation
annoncées pour début 2024
auparavant il faut cependant clarifier
la situation pour couper court aux
controverses politiciennes un référendum
préalable et non apostériori je dis bien
préalable et donc indispensable pour
connaître l'avis des Alsaciens de
manière démocratique et incontestable
sans vous prononcer sur l'opportunité
d'un redécoupage du Grand Est je vous
demande donc Madame le Ministre si vous
acceptez le principe d'organiser un tel
référendum préalable
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame Dominique fort ministre
délégué chargé des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité pour
vous répondre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur maçon la question du statut de
l'Alsace au sein de la région Grand Est
depuis la création de cette dernière a
fait l'objet de débat locaux et
nationaux que nous avons tous entendu
excusez-moi j'étais située là voilà
merci comme vous le savez les deux
départements du Haut-Rhin et du Bas-Rhin
ont fusionné le premier janvier 2021
donnant naissance à la Communauté
européenne d'Alsace cette évolution
institutionnelle qui a été accompagnée
par le gouvernement et le législateur a
apporté une réponse consensuelle aux
demandes des citoyens et des élus
alsaciens elle a permis d'adapter
l'organisation des collectivités
alsaciennes aux besoins spécifiques de
leur territoire et de doter là CEA
Communauté européenne d'Alsace de
compétences supplémentaires justifiées
là aussi par les enjeux particuliers
quelle cette collectivité fait face
notamment en matière de coopération
transfrontalière cette organisation
différenciée existe donc déjà et je
crois qu'il est important que nous lui
donnions le temps de produire ses effets
sur le plan juridique notons ensemble
que le législateur a prévu que la
modification des limites territoriales
d'une région ne peut intervenir que par
le biais de la loi soit à l'initiative
du gouvernement après consultation du
conseil régional et des conseils
départementaux concernés soit à la
demande du conseil régional et des dix
conseils départementaux intéressés je
crois monsieur le sénateur que le
gouvernement a déjà largement démontré
sa volonté de permettre aux
collectivités territoriales d'adapter
leur organisation il a ainsi notamment
voulu faciliter aussi dans le cadre de
la loi 3DS la création de collectivités
territoriale unique regroupant la région
et ses conseils départementaux ce
principe d'adaptation nous est essentiel
parce qu'il permet aux collectivités de
mieux répondre aux enjeux auxquels elles
font face alors je crois donc que nous
devons d'abord pleinement investir les
possibilités que nous offre déjà la loi
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre vous avez 50 secondes pour
répliquer 53 exactement
je suis quand même un peu surpris que
vous puissiez dire que tous les
Alsaciens sont contents parce que dans
ces conditions pourquoi vous voulez pas
faire un référendum votre réponse est
n'importe quoi Madame le Ministre tout
le monde aimait content en Alsace tout
le monde est mécontent également dans
les autres départements parce que nous
sommes victimes d'une région
tentaculaire alors c'est comme vous le
dites Madame le Ministre tout le monde
est content en Alsace pourquoi vous ne
prenez aucun risque à ce moment-là
d'organiser une un référendum pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez peur d'organiser un
référendum pour demander l'avis des gens
parce que c'est pas votre point de vue
de dire que tout va bien c'est un
mensonge de dire que tout va bien s'il
est à chaque référent de à chaque
consultation par biais de sondage on
constate que les Alsaciens sont
mécontents et qu'il y a également en
Lorraine et en Champagne-Ardenne une
majorité de gens qui veulent remettre en
cause la taille de la région Grand Est
alors madame le ministre je vous dis une
chose le gouvernement fait ce qu'il veut
mais il faut quand même arrêter de
mentir
chers collègues je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 14
décembre prochain 15h je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi visant
à protéger les collectivités
territoriales de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie la séance est suspendue